our next guest has a single googly eye
whereas a lentil is a hat and is a shell
oh yeah with Shoes On We're talking
about Marcel the Shell since his YouTube
debut that was back in 2010 his videos
have been viewed listen to this number
50 million times now his first movie is
nominated for the Academy Award for best
animated feature wow Marcel the Shell
with Shoes On follows Marcel's as it
follows Marcel as he attempts to find
his long-lost family in this clip Marcel
reacts to comments on his video after it
goes viral
you know there's nothing in here about
finding them
there's so much nothing
he's the best see
what but my dad has pink shoes so do my
grandfather
so cute
peace uh yeah obviously peace
like what a weird thing to try to test
to see if someone else is into like of
course I'm into peace
no sorry I'm a real war person
no war actually I signed all my personal
letters War
let the battle begin Marcel
Marcel the Shell is making his very
first TV appearance we're very happy to
say we got him his voice and co-creator
actor and comedian Jenny slate is also
with us Jenny good to see you too first
on CBS mornings first let's start off
congratulations and Oscar nomination
when you and your your partner at the
time Dean Fisher Camp decided came up
with his character You couldn't possibly
have dreamed of an Oscar nomination no
certainly not so so what were you guys
trying to do well I was just doing this
silly little voice that I started doing
one weekend when we were sharing a hotel
room with a bunch of friends and trying
to save some money and
um I had spent the last year on SNL just
like trying to do any voice or face that
I could do I kind of thought I had
nothing left but then this little voice
popped out and Dean had promised a
friend of ours that he would make a
short film for their live comedy show in
Brooklyn and he hadn't done it yet and
we were he was sort of like uh can I
interview that voice that you're doing
and maybe I'll make something and that's
just how it started yeah it's like you
think what do I have to offer and you go
hey it's my voice yeah so then you get
nominated for number one how did you
find out you were nominated what'd you
think
um there were a lot of text messages
that came in I had been up all night
with my daughter I just gone to sleep so
you weren't watching the nomination I
was not no and I I sort of uh yeah I
just try to let things roll through I
guess but I got a lot of text messages
from my sisters and I was like oh I
think they're probably texting to say
you know better luck next door yeah like
why didn't they call but in fact um it
was my family not wanting to wake me up
and texting to say congrats and then our
producer Elizabeth Holm called me and I
shed a tear but not too loudly because I
didn't want to wake up the baby people
experience Marcel there's there's this
sense of Joy yeah um almost childlike
wonderment you have it's like you're
reliving your own childhood what does
Marcel mean to you well I think there is
that but something that maybe happens to
some of us is that when we're young
we're allowed to wonder and we're
allowed to experiment and we're allowed
to assess our emotions as they're
happening because they're new sometimes
for the first time and then kind of gets
like shamed or just somehow like we lose
it yes and one of the best things I
think about being an adult is that you
have all the freedom that you didn't
have as a child you have the opportunity
to try to get back that wonder and I do
think that is one of the many things
that this character means to me is like
really the opportunity to get inside of
that feeling of like every day is new I
want to be alive in my life as I'm
living it and feel it and
um that's how I try to live too yeah me
too how did you decide on his look
because he's not the cutest thing he's a
little quirky looking oh a seashell a
seashell a seashell with shoes how did
you decide on his look and his voice I
think he's you can't your voice a little
bit Marcel's just chilling by the way
yes yeah he's here and Nate notices he
has to see PBS morning's mother well he
must he must well actually Dean
Fleischer Camp is the one who completely
came up for the character design
um he took a bunch of found objects that
we had in our house and there were a few
different prototypes there were like
some other weird little guys that didn't
really make the grade but he created
Marcel he stuck the eye in there and put
it on the side of our kitchen table and
I came into the house and he said I
think he's here and I looked and I saw
him and I said oh that's definitely and
I actually think that he's very handsome
you do I do I think he's very few then I
take it back he's very handsome what you
I called quirky you call handsome yeah
this is the thing Leslie Stahl makes an
appearance I was watching the movie and
they referenced Leslie Stahl the
16-minute show so I recorded it and sent
it to Leslie I go Leslie this is the
cutest thing if you're not aware of it
they mention you they call you classic
blah blah blah little did I know that
Leslie's through line throughout the
movie is 60 minutes so then I felt
stupid with two o's because I said if
you're not aware
and Leslie Stone 60 Minutes play a big
role in this movie oh yeah too yes love
it so much she showed up to set I'm
ready to do this she fully interviewed
me I was in character as Marcel sitting
on the floor yes
um and also she was so lovely because
weirdly at that time I had hurt my back
and I was kind of like lying on the
floor and she emailed me to make sure I
was okay afterwards but yeah she
completely jumped into my project
um and like Dean and I and Nick Paley
our co-writer
um just really wanted her from the start
we never no they call it the Leslie show
they called 60 minutes
yeah the best line to me in the movies
when Marcel says I'm the best of myself
when I'm connected to everything
um
so can uh Gail and I be in the sequel
Marcel too
I mean how could I say no yes
you can't to our face what is your
daughter what does your daughter think
about Marcel she really likes Marcel I
don't think she knows that I'm Marcel
really um I do the voice for her but I
don't think she understands yeah yeah
that it's you know but one day can you
do Marcel can you read the prompter in
Marcel's voice
that'd be okay
no no yeah what should I say Jenny slate
Mars oh oh sell the show
you look at that thank you